I bet I can jump over the river.
said the bear.
I bet you can't.
said the kangaroo.
So the bear ran to the river.
He jumped.
Splash, went the bear.
He did not jump over the river.
I bet I can jump over the wall.
said the bear.
I bet you can't.
said the goat.
So the bear ran toward the tall wall.
He jumped.
Splat, went the bear.
He did not jump over the tall wall.
I bet I can swing on the rope.
said the bear.
I bet you can't.
said the fox.
So the bear grabbed the rope, ran, and jumped.
Snap, went the rope.
Down went the bear.
He did not swing on the rope.
I bet I can sleep all winter.
said the bear.
I bet you can't.
said the hawk.
So the bear went into a cave.
He curled up into a big ball.
Went the bear.
And he did sleep all winter.